bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj ci siamo su un
rider che non ho mai giocato in realtà
anche se uscito da un botto ormai c'è
una nuova partita prima fiera non solo
per e disse che non sono le persone
essere straordinarie semmai loro iphone
ma le loro auto partiranno minchia che
gioca ma con l'avventura a trovare me
cioè sta rigiocando acli a clash of
plants quando la vita ci scorre da parte
uno stimolo a proseguire
vabbè è quel tizio che arrivato né che
sei stato tu a fare chissà cosa unica
pensavo diventasse hulk e da un momento
all'altro ma che cazzo successo
e godzilla colpito la nave è impossibile
una donna
[Applauso]
quanto ben di dio in acqua scherzo e
gran figata rega cliniche inizio
spettacolo non pensavo che credo io c'è
vorrei capire cosa ha distrutto quella
nave che ancora vanno male si capirà
forse più avanti non lo so per una
figata da questo ne siamo su un'isola
completamente a caso fantastico la nave
noi
ma c'è altra gente fantastica
anche tipo lost è uguale
[Musica]
mi devo muovere
chi è stato ma brutto stronzo siamo
sopravvissuti su quest'isola ci
prendiamo a calci lurido pezzente tipo
the forest fantastico che mi ha preso
lurido maniaco solo perché ciò due tette
grosse è la madonna che tra j
ma chi è che vi sta tirando su ti fai
vedere lurido maledetto maniaco fatti
vedere mostrati a me non hai una bella
cera zia ma perché poi li deve appendere
al soffitto e non le capisco spero che
cosa ci deve fare con questa tizia a ok
muoviti a sinistra destra tempo con
oscillazioni per la tia spinta ok se
aiuto magari non lo gridare che quel
tizio si sveglia e tira di gridare
lurida gang fai casino ti viene a
trovare quel pezzente ma dai
che sorpresa di situazioni di mero solo
io ma dai guarda che adesso non è che
stai messa così bene lo dico ce l'ha
fatta series andato poco perfetto vai
vai vai
[Musica]
e vabbè ma che cazzo di sfida però
diciamo una cosa un chiodo celebre
santino santo ma veramente schifo
minchia che brutta cosa se io pensavo
che lara croft fosse la intoccabile
mettiamo col cazzo che dolore assurdo no
vabbè dai seriamente manco bear grylls
staccato come lo schifo giorno no no
stai tranquillo adesso usciamo tanto ce
l'ha il navigatore verona non lo so
guarda su google maps via tutto ciò è
l'iphone ma guarda secondo me non hanno
giocato a carte
dico questo una città una fiaccola dove
è previsto ma qua perfetti che offre
venuto a caso ma va veramente stai solo
urlando da un'ora e mezza di mito del
vado di qua non c'è non ci sono segreti
da qualche parte che non vede vero avrà
assenti ma dai sei tipo orlando da
un'ora e mezza di minuti e poi sono in
una caverna non è che mi convenga tanto
ma ste cagate esatto era proprio quello
che intendevo
[Musica]
cazzo è jack sparrow bastardo
togliti dai [ __ ] via ripa via di qua
perfetto lurido maniaco se volevi
aiutare che volevi le tecniche basta
ancora
e che cazzo vuoi pronta ma quel tizio
lino in teoria intrappolato là dentro 15
crepa io spero di sì e poi non lo so le
madonne ok brava brava zia è questo che
volevo
ci voleva trova una via d'uscita la boe
ma non è che stavo giocando a monocoli
prima io ragazzi non vorrei dire però
che questa qua c'è già un foro di 12
metri nello stomaco e va tranquilla
fosse stato qualsiasi altro uomo sulla
terra a me compreso lo avrebbe iniziato
a contare i cuccioli cerca amici in
attesa di morire chissà cosa ho fatto
ma seriamente tanta roba non so neanche
io come ho fatto
non credevo si potesse parlare anche a
fuoco mai così perfetto che devono fare
adesso ma dopo lo butto ma esplode la
vita
è un gioco privo d'azione ragazze via
via via via via corri corri d'onda corri
col cazzo
vedo la luce spendo alla luce e non è
una patata è niente abbiamo provato
ragazzi pazienza lo stivale
devo anceschi va cioè la nicchia questo
gara legata alla madonna c'è di nuovo la
luce dai così vai così veloce veloce se
arriviamo a madonna che la perla nera di
soldi ma dove cazzo siamo mica un museo
ora continua a caso
chen aveva ancora lurido maniaco hai
rotto il cazzo jack sparrow di merda ma
[ __ ] ce l'ho fatta
spiace sia a capire dove dovrei arrivare
perché ancora abbiamo finito di correre
far cagate questa è la stessa scena di
gandalf solo che gandalf non è riuscito
a tirarsi su ios
vai vai vai perfetto così ho schivato
rega corso a cazzo schivato legame vai
vai vai tipo gollum vai così
io sto scrivendo robe senza capire come
lo schivando e basta sono fatta
ed è così ragazzi che andavo a scuola io
la mattina
più o meno la stessa cosa complimenti
veramente fatto un contratto cioè il
mezzo stomaco di fuori ma ok ma ci sono
altri sopravvissuti sono l'unica
[ __ ] così ce n'erano prima però blu
tomb raider fantastico a passo già
muovermi perfetto fantastico ragazzi era
già così è na figata comunque siamo
sudan rider che roba epica quanto vedo
da avevo giocato la piccola lara croft
però questa fatemi trovare prima i
superstiti perché minchia non sono solo
un deficiente ancora non ho capito
perché nell'entroterra certo portanza
che non devi ad ammazzarti prima però
che vedo che stai facendo cose
pericolose ma guarda io ci ballare la
samba non mi do the nel suo vado speech
e mentore orca merda io non vorrei dire
questa allo stomaco affitto da una
spalla un altro porto ci sei tu te
figari velayat smetto tengo a freni
misti input che cazzo è sta roba
se è uguale a lost questo che accade e
accadrà tra poco l'hanno presa per un
parcheggio di relitti sta cazzo di isola
questa devo fare non ho capito regalava
ci provo sì devo fare così le mie bragg
rapporti perfetto ma tra tutte le cose
doveva per forza aggrapparti su un cazzo
di aeroplano fatemi capire chi sa che
casino lanciati cioè io non vorrei brava
hai risolto tutto
ok perfetto basta che non mi crolli
addosso meraviglioso ok ce l'abbia fatta
l'importante questa brava zia gravati
affidiamo le medaglie al green sarebbe
fiero di te fratello cazzo e se rendilo
che ci sarà qualcosa dentro una
videocamera facevi facevo ai ragazzi un
questa faccio i blog sull'isola
se c'è connessione l'icarico segui le
tracce dei superstiti va bene dai
chimici a questi si lasciano dietro dei
giubbotti sono morto anno doveva andare
così minchia pensavo di essere il
deficiente certo che ziamika china sfiga
che lamenta basta però family park penso
bello promette bene ragazzi va bene
cerchiamo del cibo
io cercherei meglio del mcdonald cazzola
possiamo fare caccia possiamo fare mai
corri però mai come facciano anche un
arco come non fate finta di niente come
cazzo ci arrivò la società ok perfetto
va veloce non posso cacciare a mani nude
sì ho capito zia fa dammi un attimo me
la prendo per le situazioni di merda
ogni volta non c'è verso ti devi
aggrappare a un cadavere zia tutto
quanto è bello tra l'altro lega adesso
veloce sì l'ho preso tira tira ecco chi
cadrà mica addosso a no
che strano va beh avrei giurato fosse
diverso figlia la vera è che ti mangia
viva e morto arco lungo improvvisato
nuova attrezzatura perfetto anch'io c'è
una fame la madonna zia però ordino la
pizza ma possa ammazzare dei corvi tipo
si premia per raccogliere questo
l'omaggio più che la mega mangia crudo
bene
madonna meglio di hunger games tardo
evviva vive ancora vivo ancora vivo con
la prima donna che mi rallegra che mira
le medaglie voglio quante medaglie mi
piovono addosso
manco katniss everdeen fare tipo gli
hunger games costa grafica non ci
fossero mai a proprio sofisticata così
ci fai vedere proprio tutto mentre gli
aprì le budella oppure ok no niente
facciamo vedere tutto perfetto
vabbè dai zia buon appetito che ti devo
dire ci hai un mac daino che è sempre
meglio di un mac bacon allora vai così
poi ti lavi i denti e però tornare al
campamento quella carne comunque ragazzi
ho trovato un narco il che è fantastico
per iniziare almeno posso difendermi
europea ha già punti esperienza
fantastico l'istinto animale l'istinto
di sopravvivenza evidenza il cibo e
selvaggina nei paraggi perfetto ormai
premi cooper istinto di sopravvivenza va
bene ma è così poi mi sono ritrovato con
jack sparrow e ho visto un cadavere ma
che sei stronzo affari quota
attraversato le antiche rovine
per una gnocca così pure c'è ma vi avrei
pedalato pure qua bit comunque ragazzi
[ __ ] a tutto non importa se non mi
vengano a prendere l'importante è che io
sia abbastanza smart da sopravvivere si
è aperta la porta non era aperta prima
regata non lo dico che non era aperta
chi cazzo è entrato qua dentro
i ragazzi concluso più episodio che un
team and roll e il prossimo fatemi
sapere se volete che lo continui perché
è una sorta di esperimento siccome un
gioco un po diverso dal solito cosa se
tu sei video è piaciuto lasciato momento
mi piace anche a pace di facebook e con
animi la tradizione senza vestiti
fratricidi diavolo fossero vita della
ragazza